[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouvel
entretien politique sur tv 78 en ce mois
de janvier nous allons aller à la
rencontre des nouveaux maires de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines élu pour la première fois en
2020 nous allons parler de leur projet
et puis faire un premier bilan de leur
action également aujourd'hui je reçois
ali rabais bonjour bonjour et tout
d'abord meilleurs voeux à vous comme le
veut l'usagé
avant de parler de votre mandat de vos
actions peut être un mot tout de même
sur ce triste début d'année avec la
disparition d'yves unwin soldats de 33
ans tués au mali elle est né à trappes
elle y avait fait sa scolarité également
vous avez témoignée en tout cas fait
preuve de votre émotion sur les réseaux
en effet au delà de l'émotion du maire
c'est l'ensemble de la population
trappistes qui a été touché c'est une
élève un enfant entre qui est passé par
plusieurs établissements scolaires par
l'école wallon le collège gagarine le
lycée de la plaine de nos dons qu'elle a
fait l'ensemble de sa scolarité sur la
commune de trappes a embrassé ce beau
métier de militaire il a choisi de
servir la nation
donc c'est une offense trappe sacrifier
au combat pour défendre les valeurs de
la france à l'étranger pour défendre
également le peuple malien est donc la
tristesse c'est quand même assez
largement à partager au sein de la
commune de trappes
on a reçu de très nombreux témoignages
d'hommage à la mémoire d'yvon urines et
sa famille en relation avec la
collectivité également pour réfléchir
ensemble à l'hommage qu'elle mérite
mais que nous lui rendrons
collectivement il y aura un hommage ou
et qui sera organisée prochainement par
la commune tout à fait on est en train
de travailler autour de l'inhumation de
divonne win qui a souhaité son entourage
a souhaité qu'elles soient inhumés sur
la ville de trappes où elle a grandi
donc c'est un privilège et un honneur
nous allons donc organiser les choses
pour que cette inhumation permettent de
lui rendre les honneurs qu'elle mérite
au nom de la nation et au nom de la
ville de trappes et de ses habitants ali
rabais vous avez été élue en juillet
dernier à 35 ans maire de trappes à
l'issue d'une campagne qui a été tout de
même assez difficile il ya deux
adversaires
face à vous particulièrement le maire
sortant guy malandain et puis le
conseiller régional othman nasri on va
parler de votre projet forcément et puis
de vos premiers mois d'action
néanmoins cette campagne bien qu'elle
soit terminée il ya encore des recours
qui sont qui sont en cours et d'ici
quelques semaines quelques mois c'est le
tribunal administratif qui va se
prononcer dans quel état d'esprit êtes
vous moi j'ai totalement serein vous
savez j'ai quand je me suis engagé en
campagne beaucoup n'imaginais pas que je
puisse remporter cette victoire j'ai
remporté une belle victoire avec
effectivement défi majeur celui de me
présenter face à l'ancien maire de
trappes les malandrins qui a réalisé de
belles choses pour la commune mais qui
au terme de vingt ans avait fait le tour
et contre également comme l'a soutenu
par toute la droite à un régional
départemental local et qui imaginaient
que naturellement il deviendrait le
successeur de guy maddin donc évidemment
cette lan ont été contrariés et ce sont
les trappistes qui décide alors d
mourtis et les habitants qui choisissent
le projet les hommes et les femmes
chargés de le porter et mon projet a
nettement repris l'assentiment des
trappistes au premier tour j'ai gagné
avec plus de 10 points d'avance ensuite
mes adversaires se sont dans une forme
d' alliance de la carpe et du lapin se
sont aidés entre les deux tours
guy maddin d'ailleurs certains égards a
souhaité la victoire d'autres menaces où
il a même voté pour lui au moment de
l'élection du maire de trappes et j'ai
quand même remporté sept victoires et
j'en suis d'autant plus fier ce n'était
pas simple pour un jeune homme de 35 ans
vous lui disiez de remporter une
victoire au smic l'attend face à deux
adversaires et aujourd'hui nous sommes
au travail c'est ce qui compte
servir les trappistes alors certains
n'ont pas accepté leur défaite en
particulier monsieur n'à ce trou
monsieur larbaoui un peu comme on le
voit en ce moment donald trump qui est
dans une forme de déni aux états unis sa
défaite qui s'accroche au pouvoir et
compris en déclenchant le pire ici
localement heureusement la situation est
moins dramatique mais honda geico
justement la fête
vous êtes arrivé avec une situation
particulièrement dramatique qui concerne
la démocratie et les états unis et qui
touchent forcément tous les pays mais
c'est démocrates mais j'aimerais
néanmoins injuste sur le fond le
tribunal heures
dion le verdict des urnes la trappe il a
été clair et net
pour ceux qui connaissent comme moi un
peu le droit électoral gagné l'élection
avec 160 et une voix d'avancé
il ya aucun tribunal qu'il annulera
jamais cette élection et autres m'a même
si vous savez que quand nous n'avons
d'ailleurs la vidéo finale pardon ses
proches qui l'accompagnent sapin et
d'émettre leurs cours est destiné vouée
à l'échec
mais les mène une forme de guérilla pour
détourner l'attention des trappistes des
vrais sujets c'est à dire les réformes
que nous menons et qui me préoccupe moi
et mon équipe au quotidien moi je
m'occupe des vrais problèmes et des
difficultés que rencontrent les
trappistes et je tente de trouver des
solutions au quotidien pour défendre les
locataires face aux bailleurs pour faire
en sorte que ici des gens et du
chauffage tout simplement dans leur
appartement l'hiver ce n'est pas le cas
partout pour faire en sorte que le
projet d'enfouissement de la route
nationale 10 aboutisse pour faire en
sorte également qu'à l'école des enfants
et de meilleures conditions de réussite
voilà mon escrime au cul pendant que les
autres multiplient les recours aux
tribunaux mais où ne vous inquiétez pas
les tribunaux vont nous donner raison
dans les semaines qui viennent on
attendra le verdict est effectivement et
vous l'avez dit vous êtes serein en
attendant ce dernier parlons justement
des projets vous en avez abordé
quelques-uns les premières actions vous
avez pu mener le contexte sanitaire est
resté difficile et il a été difficile
pendant le la campagne pendant les
premiers mois de mandat est ce qu'il ya
certains de vos projets aussi qu'ils ont
été revus est-ce que vous avez dû
changer vos priorités en ce début de
mandat
on a dû s'adapter évidemment comme tous
moi je me suis dès mon élection battu
pour que un centre de dépistage
s'installe à trappes donc on a commencé
par deux opérations dépistage massive au
mois de juillet au mois d'août et
ensuite avec l'autorité régionale de
santé nous avons installé un centre de
dépistage permanent près du collège
gagarine qui permet d'accueillir tous
les jours des dizaines de trappistes et
au delà dans les villes de saint quentin
en yvelines et même au delà
kevin se faire dépister ce qui permet
d'identifier des personnes positives qui
s'ignorent d'éviter que des clusters ne
se forment et c'est une façon de lutter
contre la pandémie
nous avons également dû nous réadapter
sur l'ensemble du fonctionnement des
services municipaux et on a été une
municipalité particulièrement active une
des plus actives pendant la période de
confinement le second confinement nous
avons apporté du soutien au trappistes à
travers les aides alimentaires pour les
familles qui n'ont plus besoin mais
également des kits d'activités
pédagogiques pour les enfants pour pour
les occuper notamment le week end et
quitte également pour les aînés qu'on
oublie trop souvent pendant cette
période de pandémie et qui sont
confinées à la maison qui ont besoin de
la chaleur et de la proximité de leurs
élus de leur mère de leurs
fonctionnaires municipaux qui sont venus
à domicile leur proposer des kits
d'activité fournis gratuitement par la
ville de train donc nous avons et fait
preuve de souplesse d'imagination de
disponibilité nous avons distribué des
attestation d'hébergement par exemple
nous avons fait du porte à porte pour
identifier toutes les personnes qui
avaient besoin du soutien de la
collectivité et je souhaite je tiens à
remercier les 800 agents de la ville de
trappes qui se déploie tous les jours et
qui s'adapte on a des directeurs de
services qui ont fait du boîtage de
documents administratifs
on a des personnes qui ont livré des
colis alimentaires qui habituellement
travaille au service technique au
service des sports donc ça la fonction
publique le service public c'est cela
c'est une capacité à servir les
habitants à se réorganiser à faire
preuve de réactivité et d'imagination et
la ville de trappes a été exemplaire de
ce point de vue là grâce à ses agents
nous avons également revu notre
organisation puisque comme vous le savez
par exemple aux équipements culturels
sont fermés et quand les équipements
culturels sont fermés c'est il ya des
conséquences quand même dans une commune
comme la nôtre nous avons la chance
d'avoir un cinéma librairie un bon
théâtre le cadre de la merise et nous
avons souhaité réorganiser des
animations culturelles en fin d'année en
pied d'immeuble à l'extérieur dans la
rue avec des défilés des chanteurs des
artistes qui venaient donner du plaisir
et du bonheur aux trappistes sans les
regrouper dans une salle et en leur
permettant depuis le balcon de profiter
de ses activités culturelles itinérante
en ville
et voilà nous avons fait preuve de
beaucoup de souplesse aux faire en sorte
que la vie ne s'arrête pas puisque la
vie ne s'arrête pas avec la pandémie le
confinement et que nous puissions
continuer à partager ensemble
parlons de vos différents projets vos
priorités il y en a beaucoup de dossiers
importants sur cette commune chômage
délinquance logement éducation pourra
pas forcément tous abordés mais concerne
peut-être l'éducation
la ville de trappes a été labellisé cité
éducative par l'état c'est un label qui
vise à intensifier les les prises en
charge éducative des enfants à partir de
3 ans et des jeunes jusqu'à 25 ans avant
pendant et autour du temps scolaire
aussi concrètement ça va déboucher sur
quel type de mesure et quelques l action
très concrètement une mesure très
importante que j'ai souhaité prendre dès
cet été pour qu'elle soit opérationnelle
à la rentrée de septembre nous avons
souhaité rétablir l'étude après l'école
à trappes savez peut-être pas mais il
n'y a pas de soutien scolaire organisée
à l'école élémentaire pour la
collectivité jusque là et ça a été ma
priorité est de rétablir cette étude
après l'école gratuite accessible à tous
les enfants et depuis la rentrée nous
avons plus de 1500 enfants qui en
bénéficient là je crois en latin les
deux mille enfants qui en bénéficient et
qui sont accompagnés par des enseignants
de l'éducation nationale salariées par
la ville par des animateurs diplômés qui
les aident à faire les devoirs tout
simplement pour permettre que quand il
rentre à la maison
quelle que soit la capacité des familles
à les accompagner il pu savoir réviser
les leçons du jour j'allais devoir du
lendemain et aborder plus sereinement
leur scolarité
voilà une des mesures importantes que
nous avons inscrit dans le cadre de la
cité éducative
nous avons également développé tout un
plan mercredi pour les activités
périscolaires avec la volonté de
développer les ateliers d'excellence
pour que les enfants puissent le
mercredi ensemble de loisirs
gratuitement le matin avec un service
payant d'après midi ben pouvoir tout
simplement bénéficier d'activités qui
les éveils à la culture aux
mathématiques aux sciences à l'art au
sport et ses activités elles sont
inédites attrape son nouvel encore une
fois que nous avons souhaité les rendre
accessibles à tous donc elles sont
accessibles pour un euro à l'année donc
c'est une somme symbolique
vous pouvez à la fois bénéficier de
l'étude après l'école est également
inscrire aux enfants aux activités du
mercredi matin
c'est une des priorités de mon mandat
l'école la réussite scolaire
l'excellence scolaire pour les enfants
et nous avons souhaité mettre le paquet
en vue des moyens sur ce sujet vous
parlez de vos priorités pendant la
campagne il était aussi question est là
ça concernait aussi tous les candidats
de mettre l'accent sur ces différents
logements qui sont insalubres il ya eu
ces dernières années beaucoup de
plaintes contestation et à juste titre
un peu que le souligner aussi des
habitants qui étaient dans des logements
et des conditions de vie
vraiment très difficile là aussi quelles
actions vous pouvez mettre en place
quelle main vous avez sur ce dossier la
concernant les logements insalubres il
était question de créer un service
municipal dédié à la lutte contre
l'insalubrité
absolument c'est l'une de mes grandes
priorités en effet où ils avaient bien
ciblé dès l'été j'ai reçu la plupart des
bailleurs de trappes et j'ai haussé les
drôles en disant que le soir on dîne
action de la part de la mairie trappe de
laisser faire de ces dernières années
n'était plus de mise que dorénavant la
ville allait s'impliquer dans la défense
des locataires et qu'elle souhaitait
prendre parti et qu'elle ne laisserait
plus une forme de maltraitance
s'installer se développer sur la ville
de trappes
c'est le cas aujourd'hui malheureusement
depuis des années les locataires sont
des munitions tout seul face à des
bailleurs qui ne prennent pas
suffisamment sérieux leurs
préoccupations qui vivent parfois dans
des logements insalubres
j'ai parfois vivre dans des logements
qui ne sont tout simplement pas chauffée
imaginez les fêtes de fin d'année a été
le cas dans une rue de trappes
imaginez les fêtes de fin d'année sans
chauffage imaginez noël et le jour de
l'an à 15 14 degrés dans votre
appartement avec des enfants en bas âge
et bien la mairie trap est totalement
mobilité
depuis quelques mois les bailleurs ont
compris que c'était la fin de fin de la
partie il dorénavant le maire lui-même
s'impliquait donc j'ai eu à me déplacer
moi même sur le terrain chez les
habitants pour régler les difficultés
pour les constater pour convoquer le
bailleur et lui mettre le nez dans les
difficultés qu'ils créent au quotidien
et donc nous avons un certain nombre de
bailleurs qui pour certains sont très
vertueux et jouent le jeu pour d'autres
sont beaucoup plus laxiste mais d ores
et déjà le travail produit ses fruits
puisque nous avons des investissements
importants qui sont consentis par les
bailleurs pour régler des difficultés
constatées par la ville de trappes et
objective et par le maire lui-même
nous avons créé une cellule de défense
des locataires qui réunit des cadres de
haut niveau qui vont aller dans chaque
appartement insalubre pour faire des
constats d'insalubrité multiples ont pas
4 notre force de frappe bien jusqu'ici
un seul agent chargé de l'insalubrité
vous imaginez dans une ville où vous
avez 7000 logements sociaux et également
des logements privés insalubres c'est
nettement insuffisant
donc nous sommes dorénavant quatre fois
cinq fois plus nombreux d'ailleurs à
nous mobiliser et j'ai également mandaté
un ingénieur des ponts et chaussées
un ingénieur trappistes d'ailleurs un
enfant de trappes
qui est chargé aujourd'hui de faire le
lien entre les locataires leur amicale
et les bailleurs pour avoir une
expertise municipal oro ne pas
uniquement dépendre de l'analyse et du
discours des bailleurs qui souvent est
pas forcément suffisamment transparent
suffisamment honnête donc des
difficultés qui existait parfois depuis
8 ans 10 ans soit en passe d'être réglé
ce n'est que le début
merci beaucoup à l'irb est d'avoir été
avec nous pour cet entretien politique
ne voudrais pas qu'on va aborder de
nombreux dossiers juste en un mot le
chantier de la nationale 10 va débuter
concrètement pour les trappistes juste
très rapidement dans à quelle date ils
démarrent dans les semaines qui viennent
d'abord par les préparatifs du chantier
mais effectivement premier trimestre
2010 21 le chantier commencera à se
traduire dans la réalité
d'abord par l'aménagement des espaces
notamment des arbres qui sont concernés
par le chantier et ensuite on aura le
premier rond-point qui sera retravaillé
par l'état en entrée de ville de
l'occasion de suivre ce dossier dans le
journal quotidien de la rédaction de tv
60,18 merci à lee rabais et à très
bientôt sur tv et soixante dix huit pour
un nouvel entretien politique
[Musique]